T
AND WERE HONORED TO HAVE HIM
WITH US TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON,
WERE NOT PARTICULAR PARTISAN I
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU THINK ON A
LOT OF ISSUES BUT I KNOW THAT
YOU CARE ABOUT THE PEOPLE OF THE
CITY OF CHICAGO AND ARE THRILLED
TO KNOW THAT YOU'RE RUNNING FOR
MAYOR, WOULD YOU DO IF YOU WIN?
>> THANK YOU TUCKER, I BELIEVE
IN THE GREATNESS THAT IS CHICAGO
BUT CLEARLY THIS IS NOT THE
CHICAGO THAT I GREW UP IN.
I DO NOT GROW UP IN A CITY THAT
COTTLE'S CRIMINALS AND ENABLES
BAD BEHAVIOR AND TURNS A BLIND
EYE TO THE SIDE OF VICTIMS IN
OUR CITY THAT IS LORI LIGHTFOOT.
AS MAYOR, I WOULD PROVIDE A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION, SENSE OF
LEADERSHIP AND PURPOSE TO THE
CITY OF CHICAGO THAT HASN'T SEEN
IN A WHILE.
YOU HAVE TO SUPPORT FOR
RESPONDERS GIFT TO SUPPORT OUR
POLICE TRYING TO MAINTAIN LAW
AND ORDER, WE HAVE TO REBUILD
AND GROW AN ECONOMY BY EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES AND ALLOWING
BUSINESSES TO FLOURISH AND NOT
JUST OPERATE ON A HANDOUT DRIVEN
SOCIETY NEEDS TO PROVIDE THE
BASIC SERVICES TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT THEY LIVE AND
HAVE THE SERVICES THAT THE
TAXPAYERS PROVIDE.
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT SOME PEOPLE LIKE
THE CURRENT MAYOR OF A PROBLEM
EXECUTING THAT PLAN.
I WILL NOT.
>> Tucker: IT IS PRETTY SIMPLE
ACTUALLY JUST TRY NOT TO WRECK
THE LIVES OF YOUR PEOPLE.
[LAUGHS]
DO NO HARM, EXACTLY.
BUT LORI LIGHTFOOT DID GET
ELECTED AND CHICAGO IS NOT SOME
BACKWATERS WHEN WERE BIGGEST
PLACES COME A LOT OF SMART
PEOPLE.
SOME NOT QUITE SURE HOW SHE GOT
ELECTED BUT DO YOU THINK THAT
YOU CAN BEAT HER?
>> I KNOW THAT I CAN BEAT
LORI LIGHTFOOT.
WE'VE DONE POLLS THAT SHOW THAT
THE GENERAL POPULATION OF VOTERS
IN THE CITY OF CHICAGO HAVE MADE
A DECISION ON WHETHER OR NOT SHE
DESERVES A SECOND TERM AND
OVERWHELMINGLY THAT ANSWER IS
NO.
PEOPLE IN CHICAGO WANT TO FEEL
SAFE THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN THE
CITY OF CHICAGO AS YOUR SERIES
POINTED OUT IS THAT CRIME IS OUT
OF CONTROL.
LIKE THE WILD WEST IN THE
MIDWEST IN THE CITY.
THEY WANT TO MAYOR THAT'S IN A
TAKE CHARGE AND TO TAKE
OWNERSHIP AND I VOWED TO DO
THAT.
I WILL MAKE EVERYONE'S PERSONAL
SAFETY WHETHER THEY LIVE HERE
WORK HERE OR COME HERE TO VISIT
FOR VACATION.
MY NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT HAS NEVER DONE
THAT.
LUCKY IF SHE EVEN RECOGNIZES
THAT ALONE TAKES ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR IT.
I WILL TAKE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
VIOLENCE.
I'VE STOOD UP TO GANG BANGERS
THROW MY TWO TERMS, I'VE NOT
BACK DOWN EVEN WHEN THEY DAMAGE
MY HOME, COME AT ME AT MY HOUSE,
OR EVEN MADE DEATH THREATS
AGAINST ME.
DON'T SCARE ME THE WAY THAT THEY
SCARE HER AND I WILL STAND FOR
MY PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: HAS SHE CALLED YOU
RACES YET?
>> NOT YET BUT SHE HASN'T
ACTUALLY RESPONDED, I'M SURE
SHE'S TRYING TO FIND OUT HOW TO
ATTACK ME BECAUSE SHE CAN'T USE
THE LGBTQ CARD AGAINST ME
BECAUSE SHE IS A AND I'M.
YOU CAN'T USE THE MINORITY CARD
BECAUSE SHE'S AFRICAN AMERICAN
I'M LATINO, THE ONLY THING THAT
SHE HAS LEFT IS TO TALK ABOUT
ISSUES AND WE KNOW THAT HER
POLICIES HAVE DONE MORE HARM
THAN GOOD FOR THE CITY OF
CHICAGO AND I WELCOME THAT
DEBATE.
>> Tucker: ALL OF US WHO LOVE
CHICAGO FROM AFAR ARE ROOTING
FOR YOU